did Harry Styles spit on Chris Pine
why or why not oh come on you know you
want to hear about all the drama and
Chaos that went on during the making of
don't worry darling just how chaotic was
the experience on set sit back relax and
let's review The Good The Bad and The
Spit covered number one the last thing
that comes to mind when we think of
Harry Styles is shyness yet apparently
Harry isn't always as comfortable as he
is on stage Harry Styles felt
uncomfortable and shy during intimate
scenes and sometimes just acting in
general it seems he got through it okay
though number two it seems as though
Florence also had an issue with the
film's love scenes Olivia Wilde didn't
shy away from using the prevalence of
these scenes to sell the film but
Florence wasn't too keen on that she
said when it's reduced to your intimate
scenes or to watch the most famous man
in the world go down on someone it's not
why we do it it's not why I'm in this
industry number three aka the song
Florence Pew hums through the film when
it came time to write Alice's trigger
song Olivia Wilde was looking for
someone to pen the melody she must have
forgotten that she had one of the
world's most popular musicians right
there because he volunteered and ended
up writing the song in just five minutes
it almost seems like nothing went on in
this movie without at least a little
urgency number four Harry did some other
surprising things behind the scenes
apparently Harry Styles shocked the cast
and crew when he started roaring like a
wild animal in one scene and it was
totally improvised number five that
dinner party scene is already an iconic
one it's so tension filled it almost
feels like it's a behind the scenes
moment according to Olivia though so
much went into making the dinner party
scene happen she even says I can be
really terrifying because you think well
inevitably the audience is going to get
kind of bored since it was just people
talking around a table but ultimately
the success was all in the camera work
she even says that there were mistakes
that ultimately worked and made the
scene what it was in the end number six
the don't worry darling trailer shot to
popularity quickly even without the help
of the Myriad of scandals going on
behind the scenes it did so because of
it surprisingly shall we say scandalous
nature yet this trailer was what we got
after Olivia Wilde already removed some
scenes in her words we still live in a
really puritanical Society I do think
the lack of eroticism in American Film
is kind of new then when it comes to
female pleasure it's something that we
just don't see very often unless you're
talking about queer Cinema based on that
it sounds like even more R-rated scenes
were cut from the movie's trailer that's
pretty hard hard to imagine number seven
we all know that Olivia Wilde and Harry
Styles are an item referred to as
hashtag Olivia or at least they were an
item yet while the couple has been quiet
about their lovebird status and how they
came to achieve that status it seems
that the romance was sparked while they
were working on this movie together and
not the other way around Harry and
Olivia started dating on set a source
told US Weekly Harry and Olivia had
chemistry almost instantaneously on set
it was only a matter of time before they
got together number eight ah the moment
we've all been waiting for Venice Film
Festival 2022 what unfolded here when
don't worry darling premiered and the
cast did a press junket was almost
certainly more interesting than the
movie itself there was the fact that
Florence Pugh was notably absent at
first which prompted a question at a
panel to which Olivia gave this this
extremely vague answer we're really
thrilled we'll get to celebrate her work
tonight then there was the internet's
incessant buzzing about how it looked
like Harry was completely avoiding
Olivia the entire time trouble in Harry
dice there Olivia and last but certainly
not least there's Florence Pew during
this Standing Ovation and shout out to
Nick Kroll for being that friend who's
right there with you and also ready to
leave the party early number nine while
the gossip-inducing behavior of the
don't worry darling cast at the Venice
Film Festival is plentiful certainly the
most headline-making moment was what is
now lovingly referred to as spit gate
did Harry Styles inexplicably spit on
Chris Pine's lap that's for Harry to
know and the rest of us to find out by
watching the footage over and over again
number 10. according to Olivia Wilde as
a director she always aimed for an equal
playing field on set and this meant that
she accepted ideas from everyone and
even asked actors for help with
screenwriting this is surely a good idea
in theory but it seemed it turned out
with a lot of butting heads could it be
that there were too many cooks in the
kitchen or set number 11. despite all
that Shia related drama Olivia Wilde
says that they ended up with their first
choice for Jack when Harry Styles was
cast is this the truth very unclear how
would Shia feel about hearing this no
comment number 12. well it's safe to say
that these two didn't seem to have the
uh experience working together you
wouldn't have known they were doomed
from the start in a 2019 variety actors
on actors segment Florence Pugh asked
beanie feldstein who was the star of
Olivia Wilde's major directorial debut
book smart what was it like to work with
Olivia Wilde because I am totally in
love with her number 13 another key
guest star in the don't worry darling
drama Shia LaBeouf now if you haven't
been living under a rock as of late you
know that Shia was set to play Jack in
the film until some behind the scenes
drama changed things there isn't a clear
answer to who actually removed Shia from
the cast Shaya says he quit Olivia Wilde
says she fired him and Florence Pugh
said well nothing so in a tale of he
said she said she kept her lips zipped
we can only guess as to who's correct oh
and we could listen to that super
incriminating and now Infamous Miss flow
call that helps too I think this might
be a bit of a wake-up call for Miss Flo
and I want to know if you're open to
giving this a shot number 14 what better
place to start than at the beginning
don't worry darling has a notoriously
star-studded cast but Jason Sudeikis was
the first to make a guest appearance in
the backstage Dramatics it seems that
all the public drama started back in in
April of 2022 Olivia Wilde was
presenting about her next directorial
Endeavor don't worry darling at
cinemacon 2022 when she was served
custody papers from ex-fiancee Ted lasso
star Jason Sudeikis for their two young
children this was uncomfortable to say
the least and according to Olivia it was
a deliberate attack on her ex's part
attack or not it was certainly the
beginning of an uncomfy press Journey
number 15 seeing the behind the scenes
goings-on makes it feel as though there
were constant battles going on with this
movie but the first battle actually had
nothing to do with the cast it all
started with a bidding war there were 18
offers to make the movie from Studios
and streaming services ultimately Olivia
went with new line Cinema because they
offered her the exclusive theatrical
release she was hoping for
so what do you think of all the behind
the scenes chaos from don't worry
darling tell us all about it in the
comments and if you like videos like
this like And subscribe to the things
for videos about all your favorite
entertainment news